[موسيقى]
من عام
1953 توجت الملكه اليزابيث الراحله في حفل
كلف نحو خمسين مليون جنيه استرليني واليوم
وبعد 70 عاما تقدر تكلفه تتويج ابنها
البكر تشارلز ب 100 مليون جنيه بحسب لجنه
التنظيم الفاتوره بما فيها التكاليف
الامنيه والحفل الغنائي الضخم في قلعه
واسمنسر تدفعها الحكومه نظرا الى انه حدث
دوله بمعنى ان العب يقع على الموازنه
العامه ودافع الضرائب في ظل ازمه تكلفه
معيشه يعاني منها الملايين
الملك اخذ الوضع الاقتصادي في الاعتبار
وحاول تقليص الفعاليات جزئيا ولكن اعتقد
ان الاغلبيه تؤيد اقامه حفل تتويج مشرف
لان فعاليات التتويج لا تاتي كل سنه او
حتى كل عقد ويجب ان تلتزم بمستوى عال
واحترام للتقاليد والتاريخ
وفي محاوله لمراعاه الاوضاع الاقتصاديه
قلل الملك عدد المذيعوين الى نحو 2000
مدعو مقارنه بثمانيه الاف شخص حضروا تتويج
الملك الراحله المراسم الرسميه داخل كنيسه
واسمنسور ابي ايضا تم تقليص مدتها من ثلاث
ساعات الى ما بين 90 دقيقه وساعتين كما
خصص الملك يوما يشجع فيه المواطنين على
التطوع والقيام بالاعمال الخيريه في
مجتمعهم للتجديد على اهتمامه بمساعده
الفقراء والمتضررين
الحكومه بدورها تقول ان الحفل سيجلب
مردودا سياحيا ضخما وسيعطي جرعه نشاط
للاقتصاد كما يشير المسؤولون الى حقوق
البث لقنوات حول العالم التي من المتوقع
ان تحصل الملايين من الجنيهات للموازنه
اخر حفل تتويج كان قبل 70 عاما فهو فعليا
حدث تاريخي واذا نظرنا الى احتفالات
اليوبيل البلاتينيه السنه الماضيه نقدر
انه جلب ملياري جنيه من الانفاق في
المطاعم والفنادق وفي منطقه الويست اند في
لندن المبيعات الاضافيه بلغت 80 مليون
جنيه ولا يزال جدل يدور حول الاجازه
الرسميه من مؤيد يقول انها ستدعم الاقتصاد
بنحو مليار جنيه من خلال الاستهلاك
والسياحه ومن معارض يحذر من تكلفه توقف
العمل قد تتجاوز ملياري جنيه ايا كانت
الفاتوره النهائيه لمراسم التتويج يعد
التحدي الاكبر بالنسبه للعائله الملكيه هو
اقامه احتفال يليق بض خامه هذا الحدث
التاريخي ولكن اخذا في الاعتبار الصعبات
الاقتصاديه التي يعيشها البريطانيون
كارينا كامل العربيه لندن لمتابعه المزيد
من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات